hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
kochwelt ich habe heute ein sehr
leckeres rezept für euch wie immer halt
ich mache etwas vegetarisches und zwar
gibt es heute stieß die mache ich jetzt
gleich aus kartoffeln und karotten und
insbesondere bei mir ich backe hat
gleich im waffeleisen aus aber ich zeige
euch auch die variante in der pfanne
falls ihr nestern waffeleisen habt und
ich möchte dass videos heute auch machen
unter anderem weil mich viele danach
gefragt hatten wie man in diesem food
prozessor benutzt seitdem haben sich ja
ganz viele bei mir bestellt in meinem
kitchenaid set und haben halt gefragt
wie funktioniert der und ich komme
zurecht damit ich hab den ja immer ganz
gerne weil der einfach superpraktisch
schon ganz viele möglichkeiten bietet
als makler drin würfel schneiden raspeln
kleine große scheiben machen und das
besondere schalter hat so eine
aufbewahrungsbox hat und ich das dann
halt schön im schrank verstauen kann
also anders spielt zum beispiel beim
kitchenaid mit dem gemüse treue mit dem
gemüse trommeln als mit dem gemüse
schneider und genau das zeigt euch jetzt
kurz und sage ich aber erst im alter
zutaten also ich hab hier 250 g karotten
bereits geschält 250 gramm kartoffeln
also dass geschälte gewicht eine zwiebel
hier habe ich 180 km gouda nämlich noch
zwei eier und gewürze wie salz pfeffer
chili minze thymian ich sehe sich hier
um mit mitteln des karts muss frischer
und eventuell brauchen wir noch ein
bisschen mehl also zwei drei esslöffel
um das ganze halt zu binden
und ich habe ja schon mal gezeigt den
food prozessor setzt man halt da vorne
an muss denn hier reinstecken
zu drehen wenn wir mit den net hat kann
man natürlich auch ganz normal seine
gemüse reiben immer aber mit dem jedes
natürlich schneller
dann suche ich mir einfach so ein
aufsatz raus hier zwar benutzt diese
gemüse schneider und nehmen da jetzt
diese feine seite also da gibt es auch
dicke und dünne die kann man beidseitig
benutzen und ich nehme es jetzt um das
ganz fein zu schneiden
sodann muss man gerade diesen stift rein
setzen und dann hat man hier so ja das
sieht aus wie so ein viereck nutzer
keine ecken sondern rundungen und da
unten nicht aber so eine kleine ecke mit
dran
und die setzt man eben da ganz genau mit
drauf und hat deshalb schon fertig und
dann gibt's da vorne
das sieht man hier auch ganz gut zu
einem schloss einmal geöffnet einmal
geschlossen
und wenn man das jetzt hier auf diesem
fall setzt also bei ihnen daheim hat
weiß was ich meine
der hat es halt schön mit drauf ja und
jetzt kann ich direkt starten einfach
das gemüse und dem käse hier klein
machen
htc eine schüssel mit darunter sind auch
ganz gut weil da fällt das gemüse raus
also das ist jetzt nicht so wie bei
anderen mix an wo es dann darin
gesammelt wird das heißt ihr könnt jetzt
zehn kilo nacheinander machen und müsste
dann praktisch nur die schlüssel unter
auflage also es geht total schnell
so
lasst uns einfach auf höchster stufe
du musst mal einfach so für eindrücke
dann geht es immer schneller
weil es ein ganz hartes gemüse also sie
verrotten
dann gleich die nächste
liebe kann auch direkt rein aber die
groß sie mich einmal halbieren
und dann auch direkt ins leere
jetzt kann ich da oben diese scheibe
wieder entfernen da sind also zwei
löcher drin
hat sie diese so ein bisschen verfangen
weil er so klebrig dass das weiß kein
alltag oder sondern in yuma und wenn man
jetzt härter und älteren kauder nehmen
dann geht es natürlich viel besser aber
auch das funktioniert jetzt muss ich
hier oben nur einmal das kann ich euch
zeigen hängt natürlich auch ab und zu
bisserl gemüse mit drin
das könnte dann aber ganz einfach
rausnehmen mit einem löffel zum beispiel
und der food prozesse an sich ist schon
relativ sauber also den nutzerinnen
gerade mit seiner feuchten tuch abputzen
aber das hier zum beispiel kann es in
die geschirrspülmaschine dann hab das
nämlich schneller sauber jetzt gebe ich
hier noch die zwei eier mit rein
das sorgt dann eben für die bindung als
für die festigkeit ein bisschen auch
mehl dann bleibt der teig wem ich auch
schöner zusammen
es müsste einfach auch mal ausprobieren
also je nachdem wie feucht dann halt
auch das gemüse ist
ich gebe ein bisschen chili mit rein ich
kann dann später noch nachwirke etwas
thymian und etwas minze jetzt kommt bei
mir ein fast immer mit rein hab ich halt
so von meiner mama weil die das immer
benutzt dann ein gute teelöffel salz
wobei da aufpassen müsst weil der gouda
außer briefe gesalzen ist etwas frisches
muskatnuss
und pfeffer und das frühere ich jetzt
hier ganz kurz mit dem flaf früherer und
dann ist die teigmasse gleich fällt
also ich habe jetzt diese diese
teigmasse fertig um ein waffeleisen das
heißt hier schon auf also ich hab das
waffeleisen auch von kitchenaid und ich
finde es halt super weil man kann nicht
nur für waffen benutzen weil zu oft
essen wir selbst auch keine waffe
wobei darin die waffeln die sind richtig
cool denn die werden ganz dick also dass
man diese belgische waffen aber man kann
dann auch benutze für andere rezepte vor
allem halt für herzhafte und es heute
auch so ein rezept sich vegetarisch und
demokratischer trotzdem total begeistert
auch wenn kein youtube mit drin steckt
und das ist jetzt auch sowas da können
als diese tykwers vorbereite im
kühlschrank lagern und dann einfach nach
bedarf eben zubereitet
aber ihr könnt es gerne auch in einem
anderen waffeleisen ausprobieren ich
weiß nur nicht ob es funktioniert weil
bei dem es also ich kann es halt auch
zehn minuten am stück laufen lassen weil
die röschti ist also diese kartoffeln
müssen ja auch gar werden deswegen zeige
ich euch noch die alternative hier in
der pfanne
da muss mal gewissen fed benutzen also
ich habe hier etwas öl etwas olivenöl
war fleißig ist übrigens auch schon war
hab ich grad gehört dem piz und jetzt
gebe ich da so ein löffel voll mit rein
gerade so wissel platt drücken kann man
so kleine mache oder macht ein grosses
je nachdem wie ihr deshalb haben wollt
einfach mit etwa in der pfanne wird es
nicht ohne fett halbtotalen verkleben
und netze gut werden
backe ich hier mal die zwei aus und
zeigt es euch auch direkt im waffeleisen
also das muss man es vorher nicht
einfetten weil wir haben ja schon gouda
mit drin und der aura bringt schon genug
fett dem ich dann den teig rein
verteilen auch schön weil es sich ja
jetzt kein waffelteig sondern ein
festerer teig und der guten halt drin
verteilen
und es zählt jetzt auch wieviel masse da
reingeht welches zuklappen und umdrehen
und auf der anderen zeit hat auch noch
mal eine bank
und dann habe ich nämlich jetzt aus
diesem rezept zwei große waffeln und
halte diese zwei kleine hat hier auch
viel weniger arbeit als ich gibt es drei
muss mit wenden muss nicht kontrollieren
ob anbrennt
dann glaube ich das jetzt hier auch zu
und hier habe ich jetzt so eine
temperatur nahe so eine zeitanzeige und
kann jetzt hier auf diesen play knopf
drücke also auf staat machen und dann
läuft die urkunde und ich werde das
ganze dann zwei durchgänge lang machen
als ich hab jetzt auf fünf minuten 30
gestellt höher geht es halt auch nicht
wegen hitzeschutz und verbrennung schutz
und so weiter
hier muss ich aufpassen und verbrennt
man ist hier eine pfanne und dann mache
ich das ganze hat noch mal und ich
glaube dass jetzt wirklich bekommt
dunkel aber es geht
und während die zweit auspacken bereite
ich gleich noch so ein joghurt tipp mit
dazu kann auch ein quark mit einfacher
und ich hole mir ganz kurzen zutaten so
zeigte sich schnell
ich habe hier so ein bisschen
naturjoghurt 19
schön cremig auf rundes fettgehalts da
gebe ich etwas salz rhein nicht zu viel
man könnte jetzt auch in quark nehmen
oder quark mit schmand verrühren
also je nachdem was ihr da habt und auf
was sie hat lust habt ich habe es noch
ein bisschen pfeffer rein gegeben
eine prise chili und hier habe ich noch
frisch gehackten schnittlauch auch von
der terrasse kommt hier auch mit rein
ein bisschen hebe ich mir auf für die
deko verrührte sind kurz
und mittlerweile sind nämlich auch schon
meine waffeln und die rechtes fertig und
die zeit also die in der pfanne ist
jetzt etwas flach außen schön knusprig
innen weich hier von beiden seiten sind
natürlich fettiger als jetzt die aus dem
waffeleisen weil hier brauche ich ja
extra noch mal fällt mir dazu damit eben
nicht gelebt und zeigt euch jetzt mal
die die ich hier drin gemacht die db
hierauf abkühlen gitter wenn ich jetzt
gleich ausmacht ich habs jetzt bitte
warten lassen wenn sie sogar schön
knusprig aber ich jetzt jetzt will darin
stehe lasse
hier kann man im prinzip alles mit rein
geben was man möchte also zum beispiel
auch zucchini wenn man das grab daheim
hat kürbis wird vielleicht auch gehen
spinat oder ich eigentlich gar alles was
ihr da habt auf jeden fall kartoffeln
halt weil die halt so diese auch zu
binden mit dem mittelmeer das jetzt mal
auf
und dann richtig die hier einfach schön
auf eine platte an
und dann kann man die einfach so als
zwischen snack nehmen oder zb als
beilage als vorspeise je nachdem wie ihr
gehalt verwenden wollte eine zeit wo ich
jetzt diesen inneren aussieht also hier
auch eine richtig schöne farbe
zum probieren ein bisschen zu halles
wobei so ein eckchen
sie auch schön kürzlich ihr könnt auch
einen stärkeren käse nehmen also einen
würzigen käse und könnte praktisch euren
lieblings geschmack mit reinbringen und
jetzt serviert das ganze mit diesem
joghurt den was ich aber im schälchen
kann sich jeder selber auf dem teller
geben und wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr das
rezept kann nachlesen of sales - blog.de
ich finde es ist eine richtig schöne
schnelle idee vor allem ein einfaches
rezept damals passende waffeleisen de zu
hartum wenn es muss halt in der pfanne
auspacken bisserl am herd stehen
ich habe auch nicht schlimm auf jeden
fall ziemlich lecker und lohnt sich nach
zu machen und ich wünsche euch jetzt
ganz viel spaß dabei beim nachbarn
nachmachen nachkochen und wir sehen uns
dann beim nächsten mal wieder ab bis
bald